O seeker of knowledge, arise and do not sleep, for time has passed and is gone.
So, as long as you live, be mindful of it, for your mindfulness of time is the essence of
generosity. Be devoted to your studies and rejoice in them, for you will be a
leader of nations tomorrow. Hasten to seize the opportunities of your youth before the sword of old age cuts off your
resolve. Leave, as much as you can, the excess of
mixing, eating, sleeping, and speaking ill of others. Befriend the noble, and do
not be excessive, for how many an excessive person, my brother, has been deprived. And achieve
your goal, brothers of the creed,
explain the principles of the belief of the People of the Sunnah and the Community, the
creed of the Salaf, the People of Hadith, Abu
Dawud, Imam al-Harawi, Sharh al-Sunnah, Imam al-Baghawi, al-Ibanah al-Kubra, Imam Ibn Battuta, al-Uluww, Ali al-Ghaffar, Imam al-Dhahabi, Kitab al-Shari'ah, Imam Majri al-Sunnah, Khalan, Asim al-Radd 'ala Shari', Imam al-Darimi, Sahih Ibn Khuzaymah, books meaning Bukhari, Muslim, Abu Dawud, al-
Nasa'i, Ibn Majah, al-Tirmidhi, Imam Ahmad, Imam Malik, Ibn
Jarud, Ibn Abi Shaybah,
Ibn Abi Shaybah, Ibn
Abd  Al-Razzaq,
this is the Musnad of Abu Dawud al-Tayalisi, the Musnad of al-Shafi'i, the Musnad of Hamidi, the Musnad of Ibn Ja'd, the Musnad of Nahawiyyah, the Musnad of Hannad, the Musnad of al-Dalimi, the Musnad of Ya'la, Ya'la al-Mawsili, the Musnad of Imam al-Ruh al-Rawyani, the Musnad of Imam al-Shashi, the Musnad of
Firdaws, the Musnad of Bazzar, the
Musnad of
Ya'qub ibn Shaybah, like, with this chain of transmission
in the explanation, the meanings of the
narrations in the Great Dictionary, the Middle Dictionary, the Small Dictionary,
Imam al-Tabarani, Ikhwan, Tuhfat al-Ahwas, Sunan al-Tirmidhi, 'Awn al-Ma'bud,
Abu Dawud,
Fath al-Bari, the chain of transmission of the
teacher, the explanation of Sahih Muslim, the chain of transmission of Tamhid,
Muwatta' Malik, Ibn 'Abd al-
Bukhari, Tafsir Fath al-Qadir, al-Durr al-Manthur, Tafsir Ibn Kathir, Tafsir al-Qurtubi, Tafsir al-Tabari,
Tafsir al-Imam al-Baghawi,
Imam Majri,
Imam Ibn Hajar al-Asqalani, Imta' al-Imta', Imam Ibn Hajar, this
means the chain of transmission of
parts,
books of numerous books, has a
number of the books in the science of
had he has for that  which is referred to
as the first book in the sciences of had
and that is naturally after the
has for the ris of, but the book that
was considered the first of the books in the connection
between the narrator and the conscious, Imam al-Ramzina, al-Kifaya fi Ma'rifat Usul 'Ilm al-Riwaya, Khatib al-
Baghdadi, Ma'rifat 'Ulum al-Hadith, Imam Hakim, Ithnayn Ikhwan fi al-Jami', Bayan al-'Ilm wa Fadlihi,
Ibn 'Abd al-Barna, Ikhtisar 'Ulum al-Hadith, Ibn Kathir, Fath al-Mughith, Imam al-Sakhawi, al-Nukhba, Fikr al-
Hafiz, Ibn Hajar,
numero
Ikhwan,
preserving
books
and the
Sunna,
Ikhwani,
many people saw the graves of al-Baqi', and the
death of Sheikh Rabi' bin Hadi al-Madkhali, may
God have mercy on him, may God have mercy on him and forgive him and reward him on our behalf and on behalf of
all Muslims with the best reward,
for he was a defender of the Sunna, a fighter
for its protection, Islam, may God have mercy on him.
We want youth who live in the shade of the Book of God and the Sunna of the
Messenger of God and the correct methodology of the Salaf, who have no favoritism, no compromise, no hypocrisy, nothing but
uprightness on the path of falsehood. God, Blessed and Exalted is He,
accepts the truth whether it is for him or against him and rejects
falsehood no matter what its source is
O My servants who have believed, indeed, My earth is spacious,
so worship Me.
Every soul will taste
death,
then to Us you will be returned. And
those who believed and did righteous deeds - We will raise them to
Paradise in chambers
beneath which rivers flow, abiding therein eternally.
Excellent is the reward of the workers.
[Music]